maintes fois des témoignages de
massacres ou d'exactions commises en
tchétchénie par l'armée russe ont été
collectés par les organisations des
droits de l'homme la fédération
internationale des droits de l'homme a
même dressé une liste des crimes commis
par les militaires russes et demandé la
création d'un tribunal pénal
international ce soir le document inédit
dont nous allons vous montrer des
extraits sélectionnés pour ne pas
ajouter à l'horreur des faits mais je
dois vous mettre en garde les images
vous allez voir sont difficiles à
supporter ce document fait état de ce
qui s'est passé le 5 février dernier
dans la banlieue de grozny à aldi nous
avons pu recouper presque chaque aspect
du massacre affirme une association de
défense des droits de l'homme qui ajoute
cela peut servir de preuve voici ces
images difficiles donc avec le
commentaire de françois joly
selon l'oncle ahmed aboul 29
tantôt tina
et un autre oncle à ça il attendait
tellement ce jour la fin de la guerre
que personne ne vienne les tuer qu'il
soit libre cette femme raconte le 5
février à aldi banlieue sud-ouest de
grozny les sommes qu'elles identifient
comme des soldats russes sortent les
habitants de leur maison ils leur
demandent de l'argent les menaces des
insultes
il n'y a pas que des terroristes
tchétchènes qui se sont acharnés contre
nous mais des terroristes russes
d'après cette femme les soldats russes
auraient tué près 200 personnes ce jour
là elle dit
cette cassette montre une trentaine de
cadavres certains rassemblés dans une
même pièce tous en attente de sépulture
des morts que l'on gardera quelques
jours pour témoigner de l'horreur devant
une caméra
l'horreur de ce 5 février où des soldats
ivres devenu pillards auraient
systématiquement exécuter les habitants
d'albi qui ne pouvait payer pour sauver
l'euro
des soldats qui selon la plupart des
témoignages auraient systématiquement
arracher les dents en or de leurs
victimes ces images auraient été filmées
quatre jours après le massacre d'aldi
cette cassette auraient été cachées des
semaines en tchétchénie avant qu'elle
puisse parvenir aux médias occidentaux
qui ont longuement hésité avant de la
rendre publique
il est pratiquement impossible de
certifier son authenticité
et des éléments troublants nous ont
décidé à la diffusé le 23 février une
organisation non gouvernementale human
right watch surveillance des droits de
l'homme publié l'histoire du massacre
d'albi avec une première liste de
victimes une liste établie d'après des
témoignages recueillis dans des camps de
réfugiés en ingouchie certains de ces
noms les avons retrouvés dans ce
document filmé ahmed adel rannoch dit
cette femme et son oncle elle témoigne
de son exécution devant son cadavre ou
marcoux deux offres son frère moussa
sont identifiés par des proches des
voisins qui disent que le 5 février au
88 rue simons kaya a glissé deux hommes
ouvriers ont été abattus par des soldats
russes venus vérifier les passeports
souleymane moussaïev mais aussi yacoub
moussaïev oumar moussaïev abdourahmane
you say yes youth moussaïev âgés de 27 à
77 ans tué le 5 février alors qu'ils
allaient nous dit-on chercher de l'eau
dans cette guerre où toutes les
manipulations sont permises ces images
du livre avec certitude un seul message
la violence s'exerce à destination d'une
seule population et civiles les plus
démunis